are you all ready let's do it you ready
four and a half minutes in
can an nba player be out of this world
seems
really has landed several of those
inside locals
[Applause]
rooney and rooney
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's been down since day one
doing his thing too yeah and he was
cheering on embiid we saw you going back
and forth we're here he's from here i
had to i had to show him up a little bit
but uh it's all i love and like i said
they're a really young team and they
play hard beat my team and get an
interview without me doing this
hey no i'm playing no but we saw
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this crowd fired up
oh you can't walk away like that
and then give the fake hustle of helping
him up
very disappointing defense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it early and took
isn't a server
there's a guy's taking a part of a few
defenses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay look who gets wild
chris rock with the catch
and it gives it to a kid
boy he can run for office
[Music]
huh
[Music]
feel the pain sink in my bones
[Music]
[Music]
and of all the superlatives
[Applause]
wow
you take a look chris rock sitting right
next to kobe bryant shooting the breeze
funniest man in the world telling jokes
and take a look at kobe bryant
[Applause]
[Music]
rihanna
you'll share friday
the popcorn's being shared maybe that
could be shared no
the final six
of the year broke his leg in the
training camp for the u.s
national team here's steph curry with
that quick
release
[Music]
stolen by davis puts it up
what a way to finish
near the second quarter
number six 2010. benny the bull having
some fun in front of jay-z doing the
single ladies
but jay-z's reaction and diddy's for
that he wants to smile he wants to you
kind of he's going to break out in a
second it felt like it kind of cracks
last basket for the warriors
see after that little loose ball long
rebound from draymond green
nick stouskis
left his man
justin anderson once again the sixers
got him from dallas and the new orleans
noel traitor
[Music]
the big man with the big touch
gets kevin hart out of his seat
[Applause]
jordan going to work five to shoot
that's the
inside
good night philadelphia the clarkson
dancer
[Music]
jay-z and beyonce were there sitting
next to a woman in yellow she's
leaning in to talk to jay-z and it just
doesn't seem to be going over great with
beyonce
let's look at that again in slow motion
because just watch beyonce's face here
and he's like
the other woman in the clip her name's
nicole curran she's the wife of the
majority owner of the warriors and you
can see if you zoom in she's collected
two of the infinity stones
oh she
she got a world of abuse